[Music]
thank you
one of the subplots that's quite
important both in terms of the larger
plot but also in terms of what the novel
reveals to us on the part of its writer
and what he thinks is important in
Philip K Dick's man in the High Castle
is the we could call it you know
complementarity or Clash or
supplementation of values aesthetic
values life values by each other and so
we can talk about wobby which we'll get
to in just a moment and then woo and it
all is provoked by the production and
the
sale eventually
gifting first of one particular piece of
jewelry designed by Frank Frank and sold
by the Ed Frank company that they start
to produce and sell original American
jewelry and so there's kind of a long
Meandering process but it's it's very
interesting to see all the reflections
that are built into this coming on the
part of some of the characters
particularly Robert children who's going
to be the go between the intermediary
but also become somebody convinced uh
having some Anglo-Saxon fanaticism as
tagomi is going to say so we begin with
children and the house where he's been
invited of the kasuras Paul and Betty
they are a young very stylish Japanese
couple you know forward-thinking Humane
and he uh you know goes into their place
and then we have these very interesting
observations so Betty meets uh Robert at
the door Mr Children entered bowing he
entered tasteful in the extreme and so
ascetic few pieces of lamp here a table
bookcase print on the wall the
incredible Japanese sense of Wabi it
could not be thought in English the
ability to find in simple objects of
Beauty Beyond that of the elaborate or
the ornate something to do with the
arrangement now of course notice that it
is being described in English so you
know we have kind of a funny little
Paradox here and he goes on and he's
after he's gifted them a scrimshaw
he says
um
uh here we go only now in this unrelated
situation Hattie for a moment lost the
sense that things were in the constant
process of going Askew the Wabi around
him radiations of Harmony
that is it he decided the proportion
balance they the young couple are so
close to the Dao these two young
Japanese that is why I reacted to them
before I sensed the Dao through them saw
a glimpse of it myself so there's sort
of a Transcendent experience that is
happening here through his engagement
with these two and then he goes on what
would it be like he wanted to really
know the Dao the Dao is that which first
lets in the light then the dark
occasions the interplay of the two
Primal forces so that there is always
renewal it is that which keeps it all
from wearing down the universe will
never be extinguished because just when
the darkness seems to have smothered all
to be truly Transcendent the new seeds
of light are reborn in the very depths
that is the way when the seed Falls it
falls into the earth into the soil and
beneath out of sight it comes to light
and so we've gone now from just this
this uh you know value or experience of
wobby to thinking about you know broader
metaphysical issues of the Dow
and then what happens is children is
going to take the jewelry coming from
the Ed Frank Corporation fortunately
doesn't know that Frank Frank was the
guy who came in and actually caused
trouble at his shop he takes it on
consignment which you know is kind of a
a loss in a way a short-term loss for
the Ed Frank Corporation composed of Ed
and and Frank but it's going to turn out
to have some really helpful
consequences why that well so children
decides that he's going to do this in
part because this can become a new line
for him where he doesn't have to worry
about authenticity anymore he can build
up a stock of non-historic objects
contemporary work with no historicity
real or imagined he's thinking about you
know adapting and the rule of survival
be there at the right time doing the
right thing and then he has an idea he's
like oh I can gift this piece to Betty
Robert of course is attracted to Betty
very much and he's like you know I'll
graft a gift to Betty and then he thinks
a little bit more and he's like you know
I'd better do this through the
intermediary of her husband Paul so it
doesn't raise any suspicions and he's
like this is going to be two birds with
one stone right what are the two birds
he can use it as an excuse to engage
more with Betty perhaps even develop a
romantic relationship with her but he
says it's also good for obtaining a high
place reaction this is how a new line is
introduced isn't it lovely a whole
selection back at the store drop in this
one's for you Betty right so that sets
up this very interesting conversation
which is going to take up a significant
portion of chapter 11.
chill uh chilled on is going to have a
discussion with Paul and Paul tells him
something very interesting about the
piece so first he says children says oh
maybe your wife didn't like the piece
I'm really embarrassed you know and then
Paul says well I didn't give it to my
wife and then children is thinking oh
maybe he knows what I'm trying to do but
Paul goes a different way
he says
I took the liberty of showing this to a
number of business acquaintances
individuals who share my taste for
American historic objects or for
artifacts of General artistic aesthetic
Merit none of course had ever seen such
as this before as you explain no such
contemporary work hitherto for has been
known I think too you inform that you
are the sole representative do you want
to hear their reaction
children bowed these people laughed
yet I too laugh behind my hand invisible
to you the other day when you appeared
and showed me this thing naturally to
protect your song Hua I concealed that
Amusement as you no doubt recall I
remain more or less non-committal in my
apparent reaction
Paul goes on one can easily understand
this reaction here's a piece of metal
which has been melted until it has
become shapeless it represents nothing
nor does it have design of any
intentional sort is merely amorphous one
might say it is mere content deprived of
form
and here we get the very important
Turning Point
Paul says yet I have for several days
now inspected it and for no logical
reason I feel a certain emotional
fondness why is that I may ask I do not
even project uh now projecting to this
blob is in psychological German test my
own psyche I still see no shapes or
forms but somehow it partakes of Dao you
see it is balanced the forces within
this piece are stabilized at rest this
object has made its peace with the
universe it is separated from it and
hence has managed to come to homeostasis
so what does this at this point
suggesting to us maybe this piece
created by an American
by by Frank Frank has wobby then Paul
goes on and says it does not have wobby
nor could it ever but
Robert
this object has woo
I believe you were right Sheldon said
trying to recall what Wu was
it was not a Japanese word it was
Chinese wisdom he decided or
comprehension anyhow it was highly good
so children is like ah this is great at
first I was worried and now it seems
like things are falling into place
so now Paul says something really
interesting where does it get this woo
from
well
from the hands of the artificer those
had woo and allowed that woo to flow
into this piece possibly he himself
knows only that this piece satisfies it
is complete Robert by contemplating it
we gain more woo ourselves we experience
the Tranquility Associated not with art
but with holy things
I recall a shrine and Hiroshima whereas
in the shin bone of some medieval Saint
could be examined however this is an
artifact and that was a relic this is
alive in the now whereas that merely
remained by this meditation I have come
to identify the value which this has in
opposition to historicity I am deeply
moved as you may see to have no
historicity so that's one thing and no
artistic aesthetic worth which seems to
be bad and yet to partake of some
ethereal value that is a Marvel just
because this is a miserable small
worthless looking blob that contributes
to its possessing woo and he goes on and
says one experiences awareness of Wu and
such trash as an old stick or a rusty
beer can by the side of the road however
in those cases the Woo is within the
viewer it is a religious experience here
is where something really new is
happening and artificers put Wu into the
object rather than merely witnessed the
Wu inherent in it so he says in other
words an entire new world is pointed to
by this the name for it isn't either art
for it has no form nor religion what is
it
I have pondered this pin unceasingly yet
cannot fathom it we evidently lack the
word for an object like this so you are
right it is authentically a new thing
a new thing in the on the face of the
world
and so he comes back to discuss this
with Robert and now we're going to get a
very interesting proposition happening
on the part of Paul which is actually
also a test as Robert is going to
realize and an opportunity for something
new to come into the world between them
in human relations
so first he gives it back and he says
this is uh yours you must face reality
uh with more Courage the task is yours
you are the sole agent for this think
about which way you're going to go
uh how are you going to put these
objects over in a big fashion children
says the man is telling me I'm obliged
to assume moral responsibility for the
Ed Frank jewelry crackpot neurotic
Japanese worldview nothing less than
number one spiritual and business
relationship with the jewelry tolerable
in the eyes of Paul kasura and the worst
part is that Paul certainly spoke with
authority right out of the dead center
of Japanese culture and tradition
and Paul then says to him
I have a colleague who
you may want to talk to
he says I've written out his name and
address
he's an importer he imports and exports
on a mass basis especially to South
America
he deals in immense quantity perhaps
tens of thousands of each item
uh and he says pieces like this could be
mass produced either in base metal or
plastic from a mold and then children
asks a very important question
what about woo will that remain in the
pieces and there's no answer Paul
doesn't say anything
and Paul says I advise you to see him
because these can be turned into good
luck charms to be worn by relatively
poor people a line of amulets to be
peddled all over Latin America and the
Orient most of the masses still believe
in magic as you know and children says
it sounds like there would be a good
deal of money in it and he asked was
this your idea and Paul says no
so Paul says there's a chance for you to
become extremely wealthy children says
this seems bizarre to me making good
luck charms out of art objects I can't
imagine it and then Paul says
um well it's not your natural line of
business you're devoted to the savored
esoteric myself I am the same
but don't undervalue the possibility
suggested by the Importer you and I we
have no awareness of the vast number of
uneducated they can obtain from mold
produced identical objects a joy which
would be denied to us we must suppose we
have the only one of a kind or at least
something rare possessed by a very few
and of course something truly authentic
not a model or a replica not something
to be cast by the tens of thousands
and Sheldon says aha what's what's
actually happening here
so it's a dilemma what kind of person
are you
he's actually saying children thought
which are you Robert he who the Oracle
calls the inferior man or that other for
whom all the good advice is meant you
must decide here you must Trot on one
way or the other but not both moment of
choice now and which way will the
superior man go Robert children inquired
of himself
and so he goes on and he thinks woo as
Paul would say the war of this situation
is this whatever our personal dislikes
there can be no doubt the reality lies
in the importer's direction too bad for
what we had intended we must adapt as
the Oracle States after all the
originals can still be sold in my shop
to connoisseurs Paul says you wrestle
with yourself no doubt it is such a
situation one prefers to be alone
and then children says I'll follow your
advice
now I will leave to visit the Importer
any thanks Paul for his business advice
but then he Paul stops at the door and
says American Artisans made this piece
by hand correct labor of their personal
bodies
and uh he says will they play along with
this would they be persuaded and
children says I'd Hazard they could be
persuaded Paul says yes I suppose so and
then
we see a second decision being made
something in his tone made Robert
children take a sudden note a nebulous
and peculiar emphasis there and it's
swept over children without a doubt he'd
split the ambiguity he saw
the whole Affair is a cruel dismissal of
American efforts taking place before his
eyes cynicism but God forbid he had
swallowed Hook Line and Sinker so this
is how the Japanese ruled not cruelly
with subtlety Ingenuity Timeless cunning
and he goes on he says he's broken me
but
he's also humiliated me in my race and
I'm helpless where there's no avenging
this
children is actually tempted to throw
away the artwork
but then he does something
he says
Paul
I am humiliated
and Paul asked why so Robert
and he says
I'm proud of this work there can be no
consideration of trashy good luck charms
I reject
and he says the men who made this are
American Proud artists myself included
to suggest trashy good luck charms
therefore insults us and I ask for
apology incredible prolonged Silence
Paul surveyed him one eyebrow lifted
slightly in his thin lips twitched a
smile I demand children said that was
all he could carry it no further
Paul said forgive my arrogant imposition
he held out his hand
all right Robert children said they
shook hands calmness descended in
children's heart I have lived through
and out he knew all over grace of God it
existed at the exact moment for me
another time otherwise could I have ever
dare once more press my luck probably
not so interestingly they lived through
woo and through the Dao in this
situation and Sheldon who's been kind of
a in some respects
half good half bad character you know
certainly given to being a conformist
and you know kind of uh in some respects
a little scummy has displayed himself to
be the superior man and he's done so not
just on his own part
but by doing so in continuity in
solidarity with the artist
who he's representing and then we get
one more thing very interesting one more
vignette that takes place this artifact
is actually going to transport
tagomi to an alternate America but
before that he has to acquire it so he
goes to children's store to turn in the
cult revolver that he has killed the 2sd
guards with and children says no no I am
not going to buy that back from you but
he does suggest to him I want to show
you something else something of unusual
interest and so he does it and he shows
him the jewelry and he says these are
American made but these are not the old
these are the new this is the new life
of my country sir the beginning in the
form of tiny and perishable seeds of
beauty tagomi examines the pieces and he
says yes there is something new which
animates these the law of Dao is borne
out here where Yin lies everywhere the
first stirring of light is suddenly
alive in the darkest steps we are all
familiar we've seen it happen before and
yet for me these are just scraps I
cannot become wrapped as children here
here unfortunately for both of us but
that's the case
and he says quite lovely and Mr Children
says sir it does not occur at once
pardon the new view in your heart tagumi
says you are converted I wish I could be
I am not and then um
uh tagumi says you know his children is
pressing onward he says your Anglo-Saxon
fanaticism does not appeal to me
nevertheless he felt a certain renewal
of Hope
and he says I will see you again one of
these days we can perhaps examine your
prophecy
and then tagomi changes his mind as he's
leaving the story says
what if I bought one of those odd
indistinct items kept it re-examined
contemplated
what I have subsequently through it
found my way back I doubt it those are
for him not for me and yet
even if one person finds his way that
means there is a way capital W even if I
personally fail to reach it
I envy him
these are all into gomi's mind he turns
back to the store he buys one of them he
says I will buy one of these whichever
you select I have no faith but I'm
currently grasping at straws
and so Mr Children says this will calm
you he laid out a single small silver
triangle ornamented with Hollow drops
black beneath bright and light filled
above thank you Mr tagomi said and he's
going to sit there in the park
contemplating the as he calls it the
squiggle right
and then he's going to have an
experience which we'll discuss elsewhere
so what we see very interestingly
depicted articulated here thoughtfully
in great detail is how new jewelry uh by
conquered peoples who are Artisans is
able to bring something both new and old
into the world something new in its
formless form something old or Eternal
in its value of
that it is mediating making possible for
people to partake in so very important
discussion that's taking place here on
Philip K Dick's part through the
intermediary of his characters and their
actions and attitudes